[Musique]
pendant 40 millions de visiteurs donc
ils ont besoin de cette électricité et
vous le disiez le débit du fleuve
Colorado en tout cas au cours des
dernières années a été réduit du tiers
c'est immense contenu de la quantité
d'eau et c'est une tendance lourde parce
que depuis un siècle le fleuve a perdu
un cinquième de son débit donc 20 % de
son débit donc c'est vraiment une
tendance lourde pourquoi ben parce que
on se rencontre entre autres et ça j'en
ai déjà parlé ici il y a moins de neige
dans les rocheuses qui s'écoule dans le
fleuve ça c'est vraiment quelque chose
qu'on remarque il fait plus chaud des
températures sont plus hautes et donc
l'eau s'évapore plus facilement et comme
la terre est plus sèche ça prend plus
d'eau pour faire les mêmes choses
qu'avant donc on constate vraiment le
phénomène de la ridification du
Sud-Ouest comme on dit c'est vraiment en
cours et donc c'est entente est une
bonne nouvelle
qu'est-ce qu'on fait de spécial comment
ça fonctionne donc ça fait plusieurs
mois en fait que l'administration
fédérale américaine pousse les 7 États
qui sont dépendantes de ce fleuve donc
la Californie le Nevada l'Arizona le
Wyoming lutin le Colorado et le Nouveau
Mexique on leur dit entendez-vous pour
réduire la consommation d'eau parce que
au regard de la crise actuelle on va pas
y arriver et tout le monde se regarde en
chien de faïence tout le monde disait
oui mais le voisin en prend plus il peut
le faire et donc Washington c'est un peu
fâché en fait et il a un les leviers
pour le faire parce que Washington
alcool des barrages sur la rivière
Colorado on a dit aux États si vous vous
entendez pas on va couper l'eau et puis
on va peut-être couper l'électricité
aussi donc il y a quand même beaucoup de
pression et là on s'est entendu lundi on
a annoncé cette entente on va réduire
donc de 13 % le la consommation d'eau
dans les dans les trois principaux états
en aval du fleuve le Nevada l'Arizona et
la Californie 13% donc d'ici 2026 c'est
un compromis parce que c'est une entente
qui est à court terme ce sera pas
suffisant pour régler le problème à long
terme du fleuve col 13 % les experts
s'entendent pour dire que c'est pas
suffisant il faudrait réduire la
consommation d'eau du corps à peu près
et il faut avoir une programme a
beaucoup plus longtemps parce que le
début du fleuve Colorado ça ne va pas
s'arranger là au cours des prochaines
années on doit pas attendre 2026 c'est
ce qu'on a déjà commencé à s'adapter et
faire des forcément avec les sécheresses
accumulées depuis 20 ans quand vous
disiez il y a des villes qui ont
commencé à s'adapter un des bons
exemples c'est la ville de San Diego en
Californie au sud de la Californie ça
fait plus de 15 ans 20 ans que eux
commencent à mettre en place des mesures
pour réduire la consommation d'eau ils
ont refait leur système de tuyauterie
d'égout pour éviter que les que l'eau
fuit il perdait jusqu'à la moitié de
l'eau par des fuites ils ont refait tout
ça ils ont aussi incité les gens à
acheter de la plomberie très moderne
alors avec les technologies les
technologies modernes de plomberie on
prend beaucoup moins d'eau on a aussi
fait des règles sur les gazons plus
vraiment de gazon on incite les gens à
prendre la le l'aménagement paysager
local donc des plantes dans le fond qui
sont adaptés à cette espèce
d'environnement désertique on a fait la
même chose à Las Vegas en Arizona aussi
les gazons là ce sera vraiment de moins
en moins présent dans ces états du
Sud-Ouest Hassan Diego Marc-André on a
réussi à réduire la consommation la
consommation d'eau de
43%. donc ça marche et c'est ce qu'on
les c'est ce que les États doivent faire
au cours des prochains mois des
prochaines années et l'eau à San Diego
je sais j'ai un cousin qui vit là ça
coûte une fortune voilà quand
j'expliquais son fils que j'avais vidé
la piscine pour nettoyer que je l'ai
rempli il m'a regardé les yeux comme ça
on est les plus grands consommateurs
d'eau au monde au Québec vous savez
c'est là que ça coûte le moins cher que
ça coûte le moins cher aussi merci au
revoir à la prochaine merci ma connerie
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]